I didn't.
Paul Kennedy,
this is ideas,
war and violence have always been with
us.
The first murder took place between the
first humans,
Cain and Abel,
in that legacy of destroying ourselves
and each other has come down to us from
the very beginning.
The creation story reminds us as much
about our tragic weakness as it does
about our infinite potential.
As humans,
Che loss is transformed into order by
the word and you are all speakers of the
word,
and if you want chaos to be transformed
into hell,
then lie.
If you want chaos to be transformed into
heaven and tell the truth,
it's easy to look at violence and war as
anomalies of human nature,
but there's clearly something else going
on.
What's the meaning of the Columbine and
Sandy Hook school massacres,
the bus bombings in Jerusalem,
the Charlie Hebdo killings?
Sometimes we think politics can explain
these things or a kind of madness,
but what else might be behind such
senseless acts acts that achieve no goal
except the universal sadness of what the
human condition you can sweep underneath
your bed.
You don't have to go out and wave a
placard around.
I'm against poverty.
It's like,
who's for poverty?
I think you want to fix the world 65.
It's a lot harder than you think,
right?
It says in the New Testament,
it's harder to rule yourself than to
rule the city,
but why?
Well,
it turns out you're more complicated
than a city.
It also turns out that you're more
important in some sense,
the city,
Jordan Peterson is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto
and a clinical psychologist at the
Stratford Festival.
He explored some of these questions and
in today's program we'll hear the talk
he gave and the conversation I had with
him afterwards.
Here's a history of violence.
If you do a genuine psychological
analysis of the human thirst for war,
you can't entertain a more brutal topic,
and part of the reason that people don't
understand it is because you really
don't want to understand it.
So despite that,
I'm going to use a case history today.
Fundamentally,
to illustrate the state of mind that you
have to occupy in order to be willing
and ready to commit any atrocity that
might be demanded of you under any
circumstances whatsoever.
The best way to think about the human
thirst for war,
at least at the level of analysis that
I'm capable of,
is to think about it as a personality.
Lots of the states of mind that
possesses us can be reasonably thought
of as a personality,
so if you're angry,
for example,
you can think of yourself as possessed
by aries or Mars' who's the god of war,
or if you're hopelessly in love with
making a fool of yourself,
well then you're possessed by arrows,
sir cupid or Venus,
and that really is how archaic people
pre scientific people viewed the
proclivity of people to occupy states of
mind that were quite different than
those that were characteristic of their
normal personality.
Freud really capitalized on that idea
and modernized it in some sense because
Freud viewed the human being,
as in some sense,
a loosely united collection of
subpersonalities.
We don't tend to conceptualize states of
mind anymore
as personalities,
not in the scientific literature,
but we do all the time in literature and
drama and movies
and that sort of representation is
extraordinarily compelling,
weirdly enough,
you'll pay to watch it and it is very
strange if you think about it,
because if the specter of pure
destructiveness is laid out in front of
you on a stage,
there is no logical reason to assume
that you would voluntarily expose
yourself to that,
to that and pay for the privilege of
doing so,
but you do and the reason for that.
One of the reasons for that is that you
need to know what that personality is,
partly so you can recognize elements of
it if they manifest themselves in front
of you or within you and partly because
you really can't understand good
until you understand evil,
and so if you're ever wondering why
white good itself seems to be such a
limited resource.
It's worthwhile remembering that you
don't get there without going somewhere.
You don't want to go first,
and so that's where we're going to go
today.
I'm going to start with a shakespearian
quote seems appropriate from Titus
Andronicus,
which is a very violent play.
It play that's essentially about
vengeance and one of Shakespeare's
characters says,
why should wrath be mute and fury dumb?
I am no baby.
I that with base prayers.
I should repent the evils.
I have done 10,000 worst that ever,
yet I did.
Would I perform if I might have my will,
if one good deed in all my life I did.
I do repent it from my very soul.
It's not the sort of thing that you want
to hear someone say to you.
We look for reasons why people might be
motivated to commit atrocious acts and
given our cultural standpoint at
present,
we're often looking for sociological
reasons.
Poverty,
which does not read violence by the way,
relative poverty which does lack of
education.
Ignorance.
We very seldom consider intent or
voluntary intent because the idea is
that people could voluntarily and
consciously intend.
Destructiveness is a very frightening
thought,
especially when you realize that if
people could do that to the degree that
you're a person,
you could also do that and understanding
that people could do that and that you
could means that you might be morally
obliged
to undertake a very thorough examination
of the motives for your own behavior.
The personality that I want to talk to
talk about today,
it's composed of a downward spiral and I
think that's why people,
people have always envisioned hail in
some sense as a bottomless pit of hell
is a bottomless pit because no matter
how bad it is,
there's some stupid thing you can do to
make it worse and so the spiraling is
indicative of a positive feedback loop
where a causes B and b causes c and then
c causes a and everything moves out of
control.
The case study that I want to present to
you today is one of the more literate of
the columbine killers whose name was
Eric Harris.
People wonder why the mass shooters do
what they do,
which in some sense it's quite
surprising to me because if you read
what they say,
they tell you why they do what they do.
Now,
why people don't believe that is not
clear to me,
except that I think that if you do take
them at their word,
raises all sorts of specters that we
would rather have hidden.
Eric Harris became possessed,
I would say,
of just own free choice by a personality
that was composed of ideological
rigidity,
pride,
resentment,
deception,
and vengefulness.
I'm going to read you some of his
comments about government systems.
Here's Harris's comments with regards to
ideological rigidity like the early Nazi
government.
My brain is like a sponge,
sucking up everything that sounds cool
and leaving out all that is worthless.
That's how nazi-ism was formed and
that's how I will be to Hitler and his
head.
Boys messed up a few times and it costs
him the war,
but I love their beliefs and who they
were,
what they did and what they wanted.
I love the Nazis too,
by the way.
I can't get enough of the swastika,
the SS and the Iron Cross.
It's not that he didn't understand the
Nazis.
He understood them perfectly well.
Whatever else you might say about Eric
Harris,
he wasn't stupid.
Pride people,
parents,
cops,
God teachers telling me what to do.
Think,
say,
act and everything else just makes me
not want to do it.
That's why my nickname is rebel.
Rab Actually no one is worthy of
anything unless I say they are.
I feel like God,
I wish I was having everyone being
officially lower than me already know
that I'm higher than almost anyone in
the world in terms of universal
intelligence.
I feel ever more confident,
stronger and more godlike,
and I have confidence in my ability to
see people.
I have thought too much,
relies too much,
found out too much,
and I'm too self aware to just stop what
I am thinking and go back to society
because what I do and think isn't right
or morally accepted.
No,
no,
no.
I would sooner die than betrayed my own
thoughts before I leave this worthless
place.
I will kill whoever I deemed unfit for
anything at all.
This is from paradise.
Lost
the great poem by John Milton.
These are the words that he puts into
the mouth of Satan after he's flung from
heaven,
for daring to oppose and attempt to
transcend the most high as his desire
was not only to be light God,
but to be superior to God and in some
sense he's assembled in some very
important sense.
He's a symbol or a representation you
could say which is more accurate of the
ultimate intellectual pride which says
everything I know is sufficient and
there's nothing transcendent beyond
that.
Milton has Satan say farewell,
happy fields where joy forever dwells.
Hail horrors,
hail infernal world,
and Thou profoundest.
Hail received the I knew possessor,
one who brings a mind not to be changed
by place or time
resentment.
I've noticed in my clinical practice
that there are two,
three character logical elements that
really do people in and weirdly enough,
they're not really listed in the
psychiatric list of diagnosis and
they're often also not discussed as
causal elements in the genesis of mental
illness and suffering.
Even though in my experience,
they're actually the primary causes
arrogance,
which is I already know enough
deceit,
which is I can twist the fabric of
reality in my favor for my individual
wants and I can get away with it,
which goes along with pride and
arrogance and then resentment,
which is the world is tragic,
which is of course true.
The world is unjust and tragic,
which is more debatable and the
injustice and tragedy of the world is
aimed at me specifically and unfairly.
Well,
that's just not true at all.
Resentment.
I hate you people for leaving me out of
so many fun things and no,
don't say,
well,
that's your fault because if it isn't
you.
People had my phone number and I asked
and all,
but no,
no,
no.
Don't let the weird looking.
Eric kid come along.
Oh No,
you people could have shown more
respect,
treated me better,
asked for my knowledge or guidance more.
Treated me more like a senior and maybe
I wouldn't have been as ready to carry
your heads off.
Milton again,
Paradise Lost Has Satan say.
The more I see pleasures about me,
so much more,
I feel torment within me as from the
hateful siege of contraries.
All good to me becomes Bain and in
heaven,
much worse would be my state,
but neither here seek.
I Know Norton Heaven to dwell and less
by mastering is heaven supreme,
nor hope to be myself.
Less miserable by what I seek,
but others to make such as I though
thereby worse to me.
Redound for only in destroying do I find
ease to my relentless thoughts.
Eric Harris again.
Then again,
I have always hated how I looked.
I make fun of people who look like me
sometimes without even thinking
sometimes just because I want to rip on
myself.
That's where a lot of hate grows from.
This is Richard three from Shakespeare.
Richard,
the third eye shall despair.
There is no creature,
loves me,
and if I die,
no soul will pity me.
Name,
wherefore should they?
Since that I myself find in myself,
no pity to myself.
Deception.
You know what I feel like telling about
lies.
I lie a lot,
almost constantly and to everybody just
to keep my own ass out of the water and
by the way,
I don't think I'm doing this for
attention as some people may think.
Let's see,
what are some big lies I've told?
Yeah,
I stopped smoking.
Yeah.
I'm sorry for doing it.
Not for getting caught.
No,
I haven't been making more bombs.
I wouldn't do that,
and of course countless other ones.
Yeah.
I know that I hate liars and I am one
myself.
Oh,
well it's okay if I'm a hypocrite,
but no one else because I'm higher than
you people.
No matter what you say and if you
disagree,
I would shoot you.
If you take the personality elements
that we've already discussed and you mix
them up and you let them run as a
process,
you get the positive feedback loop that
I was describing earlier and it goes
something like this and I learned this
in part from the analysis of the story
of Cain and Abel in Genesis.
The first story about real human beings
is the story about Cain and Abel because
Adam and eve were made by God,
right?
So you know you can't really call them
normal humans.
Cain and Abel are the first humans and
Cain is very resentful and deceitful and
vengeful,
and the reason for that,
which it's clearly explained in the
story,
is that cane sacrifices aren't accepted
by God.
Now it's hard for modern people to
understand what a sacrifice is because
why?
Why would you offer up to God some
remnant of an animal for example,
but you know people along while back
acted things out before they could
understand them and they had a more
concrete view of the world.
I mean they assume God was in the cosmos
because if you look up in the night sky,
especially if it's dark,
it overwhelms you.
You see the transcendent and the
infinite,
and so it's the sensation and experience
of that that allows for the attributes
of God and his dwelling place to the
heaven.
So that's not so ridiculous because you
do see the infinite when you're out
under this guy at night in the dark,
and if God's up there,
since smoke rises,
if you burn something,
well,
God can tell if what you're offering is
of quality or not.
Now we have the psychological
equivalent,
which is,
I asked my students,
what sacrifices did your parents make so
that you could go to university and of
course they can answer that in no time
flat and whether that sacrifice work
depends on how well the child does at
university,
but what that essentially means is that
this sacrifice of the parents found
favor,
well with reality,
but you can substitute God for that with
no loss of meaning and so modern people
obviously believe that if you sacrifice
properly,
then reality will shine.
It's benevolent face on you.
Otherwise we wouldn't work,
so we're not so different from those
archaic people.
Now,
Cain make sacrifices and God doesn't
like them.
Now the story's a bit in bivalent about
why it might just be the gods arbitrary.
I mean it.
There's no shortage of arbitrary ness on
the part of God.
In the Old Testament,
which is part of the reason that people
have modern people have with that book
because they say,
well,
I could never believe in a god who's
that arbitrary or even cruel,
but the ancient Israelites weren't that
foolish.
They knew that life could be that
arbitrary and cruel no matter what you
believe,
so they took me that God just has it in
for cane or it could be the cane is just
not really offering up the best quality
sacrifices and so he's trying to pull
one over on God and everyone else and in
fact,
that is what God accuses him up.
If you read the story very carefully,
Cain is mad because ables getting
everything and everyone loves able.
Lots of crops is flocks are flourishing.
All the girls love him.
Plus he's a really good guy so you can't
even hate him with good conscience,
which is extremely annoying,
especially to cane.
So king goes and has a chat with God and
he says,
what kind of stupid place if you made
here?
It means reality.
I'm like working myself to the bone and
you know,
all I get is the dregs and then there's
old able out there and you know
everything he touches turns to gold.
What's up with you,
which is kind of arrogant if you think
about it,
right?
Because he is talking to God after all.
It isn't clear that cane understands
everything about being and there's
always the possibility that it's keynes.
Fall,
could not gods,
but that isn't a hypothesis that Kayden
is willing to entertain.
So God says to him basically sin,
which means to miss the Bullseye by the
way,
crouches at your doorstep like a
predatory and sexually aroused hunting
cat and you invited in and let it have
its way with you by which he means not
only is cain attacked by sin,
so to speak,
but it's a creative union sort of
attack.
Sin Comes in and Caine plays with it,
develops it,
and puts his own twist on it,
produces something new out of it.
It's obvious decay and that God isn't
willing to take responsibility for the
terrible state of being as a consequence
of this accusation and that makes them
extremely mad,
and he kills Abel and then if you follow
the story closely,
you can see that God tells everyone else
to leave cane alone,
don't,
don't kill him,
and the reason for that is that there's
a propensity for that kind of vengeful
killing to expand exponentially out into
the community,
which in fact is what happens in the
story of Cain and Abel and the end,
the,
the last one of canes,
descendance named is actually to bull
cane and he is by tradition the first
person who makes weapons of war.
So the idea is that individual
resentment manifested as homicidal.
Rage is the precondition for the spread
of that mode of being into the broader
community and the danger there is that
will degenerate into
everyone against everyone.
Harris
moral is just another word and that's
it.
I think we are all a waste of natural
resources and should be killed off and
since humans have the ability to choose
and I'm human,
I think I will choose to kill and damage
as much as nature allows me,
so take that.
Eat Napalm and lead someone's bound to
say,
what were they thinking when we go
natural born killers or when we're
planning it,
so this is what I'm thinking.
I have a goal to destroy as much as
possible so I must not be sidetracked by
my feelings of sympathy,
mercy,
or any of that.
Keep this in mind.
I want to burn the world
now.
Part of the reason that Cain killed Abel
because Abel is favored by God
and so Kane is actually not only taking
revenge against Abel and against his own
insufficiency and to get suffering.
He's actually taking revenge against God
and being itself,
and that's actually what he wants to do.
Hate.
I'm full of hate and I love it.
I want to grab some weak little freshmen
and tear them apart like a wolf.
Show them who's God,
strangled them,
squash their head,
bite their temples into the skull,
rip off their jaw,
rip off their collarbones,
break their arms in half and twist them
around the lovely sounds of bones
cracking and flesh ripping so much to do
and so little chance.
God,
I want a torch and level everything in
this whole area,
but bonds of that size are hard to make
and plus I would need a fully loaded
eight,
10 to get every store on Wadsworth and
all the buildings downtown.
Picture half of Denver on fire just for
me and vodka.
Who was his partner?
Napalm on sides of skyscrapers and car
garages blowing up from exploded gas
tanks.
Oh Man.
That would be beautiful.
Yes.
The human race is still indeed doomed.
It just needs a few kickstarters like
me.
If I can tell you a few cities off the
map,
then great.
If you recall your history,
the Nazis came up with a final solution
to the Jewish problem.
Killed them all.
Well,
in case you haven't figured it out yet,
I say kill mankind.
No one should survive.
So I'll close this briefcase history
with a quote from Georgia,
from Faust and faust.
The figure of Satan is played by
Mephistopheles and Memphis coffees in
girth.
This formulation is a very arrogant
intellect and he has a credo which is
the articulated formulation of the
values that he lives by
the spirit I that endlessly denies and
rightly to,
for all that comes to birth,
is fit for overthrow as nothing worth
wherefore.
The world were better sterilized.
That's all that's here is evil,
recognized is gained to me and downfall,
rude and sin.
The very element type prosper in
so you can see in that the actuality,
the actuality is not only what Harris
wrote and meant,
but also what he did and what he was
planning to do,
which was much more destructive than
what he actually managed.
You see his state of possession by a set
of infinitely destructive desires and
wishes,
and you see the continual representation
of that pattern of action and thought in
literature that's evil versus good.
Classically,
that's what the world is.
That's what the cosmos is.
It's a place where evil and good
continually battle eternally battle,
and although we don't believe in such
things anymore or more accurately,
we don't know what we believe,
we still are inclined to watch that
drama present itself on stage in endless
variations,
and the reason for that is that it's
true.
You can't understand the human capacity
and desire for atrocity without viewing
it through a metaphysical lens.
You can't understand someone like Eric
Harris or the countless others who are
possessed,
so to speak,
in exactly the manner that he was
without using dramatic or religious
language because you cannot formulate
either the question or the answer with
enough profundity without that kind of
representation.
Now,
I wouldn't say that the motives that
I've discussed constitute the only
reasons for the human thirst for war,
but I can tell you that you'll never
understand the desire for atrocity
without coming to grips with the problem
of evil.
Thank you.
Your listening to ideas in Canada on CBC
radio,
one on Sirius xm across North America
and around the world on CBC dot Ca.
I'm Paul Kennedy.
What is it that drives us to violence?
Murder and war,
these are some of the most puzzling
corners of the human personality and
with the help of William Shakespeare and
John Milton,
psychologist Jordan Peterson has been
exploring mind of murder,
specifically the mind of columbine
killer,
Eric Harris.
This is a history of violence in time
now for my conversation with Jordan
Peterson and for some audience
questions,
I want to begin,
I guess sort of where you began and I,
I'd never heard the words of Eric Harris
before and I have to tell you,
I found them chilling.
Lee,
frightening.
It was interesting though to then here
you quote and it had the,
the quotations so opposite and so
perfect.
Matching a quoting from Milton and
quoting from paradise lost,
I believe.
Um,
my undergraduate memory of studying that
masterpiece.
I'm,
is that,
and I think this is a school of critical
thought as well.
Milton apparently liked to Satan more
than he liked any of the other
characters in that,
in that word,
the modern interpretation.
Why would that be modern and what do you
mean by that?
Well,
because
Milton was a genius and the way he
represented Satan in paradise lost was
as at a rebel and he didn't paint them
in black and white,
so to speak.
He gave him all the attributes than an
admirable rebel would have and people
enjoy identifying with the figure of the
admirable rebel,
but what's what Satan was rebelling
against,
wasn't what an admirable rebel would
rebel against.
He wasn't rebelling the way Christ say.
Rick rebelled in his time against the
increasing tendency of the religious
state to become dogmatic and tyrannical.
Satan was rebelling against the idea
that there was something that exceeded
his power and that was transcendent.
Well,
human beings do that all the time,
especially modern human being.
So the idea that that Satan's and
admirable character I think can't be
placed at Milton Street.
He opened the door to that
interpretation and that's a good thing
because part of,
for example,
the reason that these modes of thinking
we're so powerful and compelling to
Harris was that they,
I,
they allowed him the possibility of
construing himself as an admirable
rebel.
Even though what he was was
a momentary embodiment of the eternal
desire to obliterate everything,
and those are characters that exist to
Eric Harris,
his little lone pair,
so he had to.
He had partners in Columbine.
He has admiral admires on the web of no
small number and not only does he exist
out there,
he also exists in here,
like the thing that he represents,
the thing that he embodied is not.
It's a.
it's a permanent element of the human
psyche.
It's in a radical,
it's eternal,
it's architectural,
it's structural.
So and why it's structural.
It's Harris does a good job of
explaining.
Everyone knows that life is and everyone
knows that to exist is to suffer and one
logical and appropriate response to that
is to be grateful in spite of your
suffering and attempt to make the best
of it and perhaps to alleviate that
where you can and another is to take the
perspective of Mephistopheles and to say
no,
no.
The whole thing is flawed right from the
beginning.
If this much suffering is the price of
being than we should just eradicate the
whole mess and people think like that
all the time.
I'm curious,
you worked literally as an academic
professor of psychology.
You also have a practice here.
Do you have a clinical practice?
Is there any possible use for these
great icons,
sort of Western or eastern?
Any literature which all have in them,
as you say,
the sort of balance or,
or opposition of good and evil.
Um,
is there any possible clinical use for
that?
Oh,
if you see people who are really in
trouble,
like really in trouble,
you can't address their problems without
using architectural language.
It's not possible.
So for example,
I had a client who lived in a web of
lies that was pretty much infinite.
I tried for years to get to the bottom
of it.
Familial lies.
The lie was we love you and we're
helping you.
When the truth was,
you should have been born a boy and
we've hated you ever since you were
born.
But we're not going to tell you that and
we're not gonna.
Let anyone else know that because we
need a facade of benevolence now and for
her,
this person to even begin to understand
what was going on in her family.
There was no escaping archetipal
language.
I mean it was hellish.
People died in that house and I made
very little headway.
Every time I go to the bottom of some
absolutely horrendous betrayal,
betrayers we're in Dante's inferno.
They were right in the center of hell,
right?
They were the worst of the criminals,
so to speak.
I'd get to the bottom of some God awful
decades long,
brilliantly played betrayal,
and there'd be another one at the bottom
of that.
I was wondering specifically whether
you'd actually used text in conversation
with patients.
So you would talk about foster,
you know,
lots of my patients have come from
religious backgrounds.
I mean one of them was a relatively
unsuccessful chaplain who was suddenly
fired from her job and then was hit by a
car.
So that wasn't a good day.
I'm all in one day.
Yes,
yes.
And there was just,
there was no escaping the religious
dimension.
I mean,
the thing about religious,
the religious dimension sits at the
bottom of life.
Many people don't understand that.
They think it's a set of superstitions.
It's like it's not a set of
superstitions,
or if it is,
then you might ask yourself,
well,
why do you continue to go see it played
out time and time again on stage?
What are you just entertaining yourself?
It's like you're not.
Whether you know it or not,
you're educating yourself.
You're seeing near archetipal
representations of the structural
elements of human behavior laid out for
you by geniuses dramatically and part of
the reason that you get the information
that way is that you're not smart enough
to understand it abstractly and neither
is anyone else.
It's so complicated that even now all we
can really do is see it played out.
It's very difficult for us to transform
that into fully articulated philosophy.
Like it took me 15 years of work,
three hours a day to develop the ideas
that and really like that was every day
I was thinking about this obsessively
for for decades and it took me that long
to reach the level of articulation where
I could tell the story I told today it's
like it's complicated material and so
it's also predicated on the idea which
which I believe to be true is that
reality itself is a forum for action.
It's not a place of objective things and
I believe that.
I also believe that if you're a true
Darwinian,
you have to believe that because Darwin
believe that we are selected for
survival as a consequence of our
actions,
and so our actions are what actually
constitute the fundamental truth.
You live or die by your actions.
While actions have patterns,
we have character,
we have a nature.
That's why you can well,
that's why dramatic representations can
be distributed worldwide and everyone
understands them and we understand them
in some sense innately,
and we're drawn to them.
I Remember I showed Pinocchio to my son
when he was about four.
Pinocchio is a story about confronting
chaos and rescuing history in order to
become a genuine human being.
That's Pinocchio goes to the bottom of
the ocean to confront chaos in the form
of a whale and he rescues his father and
that makes him a fully developed human
being.
That's a story that the Egyptians tooled
for thousand years ago.
It's a very old story.
My son must've watched that 30 times.
You know,
he was really in some sense obsessed
with it.
Well,
not really.
Pinocchio has so much information and
you can barely begin to calculate it and
you know,
you could tell that by watching its
effect on someone whose mind was just
starting to develop and he was terrified
of that whale,
but he wouldn't stop watching it.
You know,
we used to tell them,
keep your eye on the hero,
right?
Because,
you know,
should you show your children
frightening things?
Well the world is frightening.
You're going to shelter them from that.
Then all you do is launch them out into
the world like,
like edible.
Pray.
It's a bad idea.
So,
you know,
you have to tell the children what to do
and that's to keep your eye on the hero
because despite the fact that it's
dangerous,
he prevails.
That's the story of humanity.
It's not while the heroes,
you know,
quivering at the back of the cave,
waiting for someone else to do the dirty
work.
I guess I'm wondering how we might take
the archetypes you're talking about in
literature and theater in art and
creative world.
Um,
and somehow connect them with the other
kind of world we're watching all the
time on television.
As you say,
we,
we are in a world where many of these
things are being acted out,
right?
Right before our eyes.
And it's horrifying to watch.
This is horrifying to watch television
for me these days anyway,
as it would be to read Eric Harris
journals and how can I connect what I
might learn if you,
if you.
I mean,
I tried to take apart the reasons for
atrocity in warfare particularly.
I was trying to understand how the world
could have come to the point in about
1984 where we were locked in mad mutual,
assured destruction mode.
How in the world is that the world that
we could have constituted the world so
that we're aiming at each other's mutual
destruction with a weapon capacity that
was exponentially beyond that.
It seemed like a mystery and I tried
different levels of analysis,
you know,
because my first degree was political
science,
so I tried political and economic and
sociological and until I got to the
psychological and then to the
psychodynamic,
I didn't really have much luck because
you see what I was trying to understand.
For example,
it wasn't so much territorial war,
you know,
I can kinda understand.
You have something I wanted so you know,
I'll push you out of the way animals do
that.
I mean it's not,
it's by no means,
right?
But it's understandable.
But there are,
there are endless stories say about
occurrences in the 20th century,
some of them that you can't even read
without developing posttraumatic stress
disorder of gratuitous violence.
So one example,
it's always haunted me.
It's an example from Auschwitz was that
game that the guards used to play.
There were,
you know,
that the people that were being
incarcerated would arrive at the camps
and of course they're already terrorized
and half dead or completely dead and
ripped out of their lives and thrown in
with people they don't understand and
whose language they don't speak and
demolished in multiple ways and you
know,
they'd have them carry wet socks of salt
on their backs from one side of the
compound to the other and back.
It's like,
okay,
just exactly.
Why do you want to do that?
Well,
that's a messy question,
you know,
when I don't think you can understand it
until you understand,
understand the part of you that could do
that.
And one of the horrifying things about
this line of investigation is that
that part exists.
And you could understand that,
but you probably won't.
And it's no bloody wonder.
So
when I started the psychological
investigation,
I read a lot of mythology,
lot of work on comparative religion and
see the,
the religious stories are the
fundamental narratives.
You know,
they sort of,
if you think of behavior or,
or drama as having a grammar,
the grammar of behavior and drama is
religious and the reason it's really
it's religious because it's the grammar.
You know what,
you can't go any deeper than that.
That's how things are.
Like the human being,
the archetypical human being is a hero,
voluntarily confronting the unknown.
That's what we are and if we're not that
we're something else and that is not a
good thing.
It's also something that you know,
and I think this is what's really
interesting about what you're saying.
I would would say,
and I may be mischaracterizing
civilization or 20th and 21st century
political reality,
but many people I think given the fact
when you say it's a fact,
and I think it is grounded in something
really archetipal and perhaps religious
really basic DNA,
there's evil and there's good.
Most people would want to say,
okay,
let's work on getting rid of evil.
And I think you,
I think you were saying no,
that's not what you have to do.
Oh No,
I think that is what you have to do,
but you don't do it by getting rid of
other people's evil.
You get,
you do it by getting rid of your own.
Like I can tell you an experiment.
You can try.
This is a great experiment.
Try not to say anything that isn't true
for a month.
You know when you say,
well,
what about white lies?
It's like,
well,
you know,
that's your problem.
You see if you can figure out how to.
So you know,
he might say,
your wife says,
how do I look in this dress?
And you know,
you don't think she looks very good and
so you say,
well you look great honey,
and that's real good,
but that isn't the right answer.
The right answer is something like,
don't ask me manipulative questions.
I know that's a little book.
It's a little harsh and I wouldn't
actually formulated that way.
I would say,
well,
you know,
I don't answer questions like that or
something like that.
So the truth wouldn't be that,
you know,
you look hideous in that dress and only
a moron would wear it.
That's,
that's not the truth.
The truth is more sophisticated than
that and you know,
people are telling lies all the time to
spare other people's feelings and they
have all sorts of good reasons for it.
It's like there are no good reasons for
lying.
You pollute your speech by lying,
and one of the most fundamental
presuppositions of western culture,
and this is I think,
the most perhaps the most brilliant
discovery human beings ever made,
is that chaos is transformed into order
by the word
and you are all speakers of the word,
and if you want chaos to be transformed
into hell,
then lie.
If you want chaos to be transformed into
heaven,
then tell the truth.
Fighting evil does matter,
but it's not corporations.
Some of them are evil,
obviously.
Some of them aren't.
You know,
it's not corporations,
it's not sociopolitical structure.
It's none of those things.
It's like fix up your speech,
fix up your family,
and then if you could manage that,
which is very difficult,
then maybe you could dare to start
thinking about something more complex
than the family level of organization.
You know,
I see students all the time,
whose lives are there are God awful
mess,
you know when they're out protesting
about something that's destroying the
world,
it's like,
well,
if we put you in charge,
well you have to decide what you're up
to
and you're either trying to make things
better or worse.
That's it.
Those are the options and if you're
trying to make them worse,
there's reason and if you're trying to
make them better,
there's a reason and so in some sense
you decide which side you're on and then
then you decide how much you're on that
side,
and a huge part of being on that side is
truth.
It's the fundamental virtue.
Without truth,
you don't know where you are.
You don't know what you're doing,
you don't know who you are,
and the only reason you think you can
get away with anything is pride.
It's like,
you know,
I'm smart enough to twist the fabric of
reality in my favor.
It's like crack.
Okay,
go ahead.
See what happens.
It's like the outcome will not be
pretty.
Even if you get what you want doing
that,
you'll find out that it doesn't do for
you what you thought it would.
So you know it's a fool's victory.
First question from the audience,
do people tend to take from plays views
that reinforce their own position even
when the play expresses a country?
Oh,
that's a good.
That's a really good question.
Art and literature truly subversive in
in the,
in,
you know,
because first of all,
if it's art,
it's not propaganda because if it's
propaganda then that's a conscious
attempt to change the way you think or
look.
But if it's art,
then what's happening is the artist is
trying to figure something out.
Well,
he or she is engaged in the act of
artistic production and then the art
object is the result of that exploratory
attempt and the thing about exploring
with art is you're always exploring
things that you don't know because
otherwise why would you be exploring?
And so part of the reason that art is
subversive is because it exists on the
border between articulated knowledge and
the unknown itself.
Like it's the place where articulated
knowledge is born and it's very
difficult to criticize art,
right?
I mean you can say,
well,
one paintings better than another,
but like what I mean by that is even
nihilistic punk rockers like music write
music seeps in.
It's like music helps them celebrate
life to the degree that nihilistic punk
rockers are capable of doing that and
they will criticize the music.
Like maybe they don't like the lyrics or
whatever,
but you're just an idiot if you
criticize music as a phenomenal logical
entity,
like dance is the same way these things
are.
In some sense they're beyond criticism
because you actually don't know what
they're about.
So Yeah,
art is really subversive or
transformative,
you know?
But that's the same thing.
This is a question that brings us right
up to the prison peer.
Suppose what should be done in Gaza?
How do we look at that currently
properly?
I don't have an answer for that.
I don't think there's anything I can do
about Gasa or alternatively I'm doing
everything I can about gas or by talking
to you here today.
And my conclusion was,
as I mentioned before,
when I was trying to figure out what
level of analysis was appropriate to
conceptualize the greatest of moral
problem,
so Gaza situations,
a good example of that,
I always ended up at the individual
level.
So I would say if you want to help the
situation in Gaza,
be more truthful with your spouse and
you would think,
well,
how can that be connected?
But I can tell you how it's connected.
You know,
you're more connected to other people
than you think.
So,
you know,
we don't live in linear relationships
with one another.
We live in network relationships.
So each of you is connected,
for example,
pretty directly to about a thousand
people over the course of your life.
Thousand people.
It's more than that probably.
But then you think,
well,
each of those thousand are connected to
a thousand.
So that's a million.
So you're one person away from a million
people and then those thousand thousand
noah thousands.
And so you're two people away from a
billion people.
And you know,
the thing that's interesting about a
network is that it has as many centers
as there are nodes and one of the.
This is something Solzhenitsyn made
explicit,
but one of the implicit presuppositions
of the Judeo Christian tradition is that
each soul is a center of the cosmos.
You think,
well,
can that be true?
It's like God only knows what's true.
What we know about consciousness you
could put in a thimble.
We know nothing about consciousness.
We haven't advanced in our understanding
fact.
We may have gone backwards over the last
400 years.
I mean we know nothing about the
relationship of the brain to conscious
awareness or virtually nothing.
Bits and pieces here and consciousness
is an absolute mystery and God only
knows where it came from or what it's up
to you.
I mean,
we know some things about human being.
We are fundamentally explorers of the
unknown.
That's how we're built.
We take things apart and put them
together and communicate the results of
that and we find pleasure in that.
But don't underestimate the utility of
getting your life together.
I mean,
besides,
you can do that.
Besides,
you're not going to hurt anyone if you
do that.
You'll just make things better.
Plus,
it's kind of humble.
It's like you can sweep underneath your
bed,
you know,
you don't have to go out and wave a
placard around.
I'm against poverty.
It's like who's for poverty?
You know,
so I think you want to fix the world,
fix your life.
It's a lot harder than you think,
right?
It says in the New Testament,
it's harder to rule yourself than to
rule the city,
but why?
Well,
it turns out you're more complicated
than a city.
It also turns out that you're more
important in some sense than a city,
and it also turns out to matter what you
do with your life,
not it matters for you and it matters
for everyone else.
And it probably matters for the destiny
of being mean.
That's what it means in some sense to be
made in God's image.
And you know,
you think,
well,
I don't take that stuff very seriously.
It's like your whole legal system is
predicated on that idea.
So don't say it.
You don't take it seriously.
You know,
you,
you presume that you have intrinsic
value,
it's a presupposition,
right?
Well,
what is intrinsic value need?
It's grounded in something,
it's transcendent value.
And even if you don't believe in it,
you act it out and you'll be very
annoyed if anybody interferes with your
transcendent value.
So who cares what you say you believe.
What do you know about yourself?
You know,
we wouldn't have psychology if we were
transparent to ourselves.
We wouldn't have drama,
you know,
just because you believe something about
who you are doesn't make it true.
So
this is back to Michael or to Eric
Harris.
Um,
what parenting or educational practices
help to develop such extreme arrogance
is displayed by somebody like Eric
Harris.
It's not self evident that it was
parenting per se that produced Harris,
you know,
and I would hesitate to lay
responsibility at his parents' feet.
People make choices,
and this is a rough one because we don't
have the science for that because the
science says,
well,
it's got to be causal in some factors.
So you look at sociological economic
causes and you know there's all these
deterministic events on the social side
and on the natural side,
nature and nurture,
that's all you are,
is nature and nurture.
It's like,
well,
maybe not.
You're also actually nature,
nurture and consciousness and
consciousness seems to be able to make
choices and the choices seem to matter.
So
you can come from a pretty wretched
family and a pretty wretched social
circumstance where absolutely everything
is stacked against you and come out
pretty damn good.
Most people who abuse their children
were abused as children.
Causal,
right?
Well,
no.
Most people who were abused as children
don't abuse their children.
The causality only works when you go
from the abuse back.
Okay?
So the pool of abused people is high.
Most of them don't abuse their children.
But if you look at child abusers,
small pool,
most of them were abused,
but you're not talking about the whole
continuum.
Most people who are abused don't abuse.
And when you know that,
because if they did think about it,
if they did,
it would spread exponentially and then
everyone would be being raised by
seriously violent,
abusive parents and would take no time
at all.
I can take a few generations and poof,
everyone would be a violent abuser.
It's like,
that doesn't happen.
So weirdly enough,
the horrors of history don't necessarily
accumulate and become transferred.
And I've seen this in my own practice.
Like I have one client who,
she had a pretty nasty upbringing.
Her mother pretty much did everything
she possibly could to make sure that she
had
no real self confidence.
And uh,
what she learned from that was not to do
that to her son.
And she raised an excellent son.
It's like she had every reason to,
you know,
perpetuate her misery as a consequence
of resentment.
And she has some resentment and it's not
surprising,
but she swore,
man,
I'm going not,
I'm not going to do this to my son.
And she did a great job.
Like,
I know her quite well and he's a.
She didn't overprotect him.
That's pretty good.
He tells the truth.
He's,
he's on a career,
you know,
he's,
he's got his career going.
He's a straightforward young guy and he
likes his mom,
you know,
so good deal,
but count for that causally.
The problem is,
and this is something you observed a
long time ago,
any event can produce multiple causal
pathways while not any event,
but you know,
any complex event so determinism,
I think the world's too complicated to
be deterministic.
So
ideas.
You've been listening to a history of
violence and exploration by psychologist
Jordan Peterson into the human lust for
violence and killing on Youtube.
You can find many of his talks that
Jordan Peterson videos.
This program was recorded at the studio
theater of the Stratford Festival.
Thanks to Michael Hart,
Robin Cheesman,
Melissa,
we're no Peter Holland and David
Campbell.
Special thanks to ants word fager
Anthony Cimolino and Kira locker.
If you want to find out more about the
show and what's coming up or to comment
on anything you've heard in the show,
check us out at our website,
CBC.ca/Ids,
and you can also find us on facebook and
twitter and history of violence was
produced by Philip Coulter.
Executive producer of ideas is Greg
Kelly.
I'm Paul Kennedy.
The hourly news is next.